[Music]
It's a scar, it's a detergency, it's a
natural thing,
it's a roll that was called a cursed Photoshop.
After that, it can't
be cured by magic.
I lived in a house in the outside world until I became eight big cities of aristocrats,
but when the trace of that aristocrat disappeared, I was welcomed into that house as a
tracer.
However, my face there was hated.
Furthermore, when I was a child, I was terribly abused by my mother-in-law.
It was a hellish day for me. My
eyes were cool,
but with Julius-sama.
Hey, don't worry about my appearance, just look at its power.
What is the magic of you now? It's magic in the world.
It's a wonderful magic that kindness is trying to protect everything.
You must join the magic knights.
[Music] It's
not like a strong family.
Kishida I
never thought about it.
[Music]
I care about nothing.
I don't really care, but if you care,
I'll give you a magic.
Julius-sama, this is too much.
[Music] I
'm glad it
's all done for this person.  It's like I heard somewhere I thought I'd give Grimwar